Would it be the total number of Web users?
Well, for an Android game, they're not on the Web.
They might hear about it on the Web,
but that's not really gonna help you understand the served available market.
Is is the total number of mobile phone users?
Well, that might be the total available market,
but you're really interested in just the Android piece
and so number 3 might make sense,
the total number of active Android users.
But if we get a little more sophisticated,
we'd understand that the real answer is number 4;
it's not only the total number of active Android users,
but they need the right level of the operating system
to support the particular game's features,
and so you really want to get the SAM
as tightly defined as you can.